This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. We all love a good surprise. In movies, we love the moment when the rug is pulled out from under us. When everything we thought we knew, turns out to be totally wrong. We love these moments so much, we even get a kick out of watching other people being surprised. WHAAAA! My God! Oh my God! In fact, there's an entire mini genre on YouTube of parents filming their children with them as they watch one of the greatest surprise scenes in movie history.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们都喜欢惊喜。在电影里，我们热爱那种地毯被猛地抽走的感觉，热爱我们自以为了解的一切最终被证明完全错误的那一刻。我们太喜欢这种时刻了，甚至看着别人感到惊讶也能让我们乐在其中。天哪！我的天哪！事实上，YouTube上有一个很火的小众板块，父母们拍摄自己和孩子一起观看电影史上最伟大的惊喜场景时的反应。
Spoiler alert, this is the showdown between our tribe's Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker in Star Wars the Empire Strikes Back. Video after video shows cute little kids peeking out from under blankets, their eyes wide as they discover the secret that the rest of the world already knows. I am your father. What? Does there is this father? Daddy is that true?
剧透预警，这就是《星球大战：帝国反击战》中我们阵营的黑武士与卢克·天行者之间的决战。一个接一个的视频显示，可爱的孩子们从毯子底下探出头来，当他们发现世界其他人早已知道的秘密时，眼睛瞪得大大的。我是你父亲。什么？真的有这个父亲吗？爸爸，那是真的吗？
It's totally true. What? That just plays as father. This week we'll find out why our tendency to be easily fooled in movies can reveal something important about the way our minds work outside the movie theater. Stories do what happens to us as we make our way through the world all the time. We're making inferences, we're trying to make sense of the world and understand what other people think, what other people know, what's going on, and what stories do is they
这完全是真的。什么？这演的就像个父亲。本周我们将探讨，为什么我们在电影中容易被忽悠的倾向，能够揭示出关于我们大脑在电影院外运作方式的重要信息。当我们在这个世界上前行时，故事不断地发生在我们的身上。我们在进行推论，我们试图理解这个世界，理解别人的想法、别人的知识、正在发生的事情，而故事所做的事就是
play on these tendencies and they exploit them to produce really piratechnic effects. We'll talk to Vera Tobin, a cognitive scientist at Case Western Reserve University. She's the author of Elements of Surprise, our mental limits and the satisfaction of plot. We're going to look at two movies from the 1990s, the sixth sense and the usual suspects. If you haven't seen those movies yet, fair warning, more spoilers are coming your way. What do you think? We think what? Do you think that's crazy?
利用这些倾向，并加以发掘，从而产生非常耀眼的效果。我们将与凯斯西储大学的认知科学家维拉·托宾交谈。她是《惊喜的要素：我们的心理极限与情节的满足感》一书的作者。我们将探讨两部20世纪90年代的电影，《第六感》和《非常嫌疑犯》。如果你还没看过这些电影，友情提示，前方高能剧透。你觉得呢？我们觉得什么？你觉得这太疯狂了吗？
Yeah. Storytellers are not neuroscientists, but they intuitively know what neuroscientists know. All of us have blind spots in the way we assess the world. We overlook key details. We forget how we know things. We see patterns that aren't there. Because these blind spots are wired into the brain, they act in ways that are predictable. So predictable that storytellers from Sophocles to M. Night Shyamalan have used them against us to lead us astray. In recent years, some scientists have begun to ask, can stories serve as a kind of brains can?
是的。讲故事的人虽然不是神经科学家，但他们凭直觉就知道神经科学家所知道的事。我们在评估世界的方式上都有盲点。我们忽视了关键细节。我们忘记了自己是如何得知某些事情的。我们看到了并不存在的模式。由于这些盲点是写进大脑里的，它们的行为方式是可预测的。这种可预测性极高，以至于从索福克勒斯到M·奈特·沙马兰这样的故事讲述者都在利用它们来对付我们，将我们引向歧途。近年来，一些科学家开始思考：故事能否充当一种大脑扫描仪？
If a surprise ending works by exploiting our biases and mental shortcuts, can observing the mechanics of a good story reveal something important about the contours of the mind? As we make our way through the world, our brains are assembling very fragmented, jagged bits of information into a coherent story for us, and what stories, films, and novels, and so on are doing is capitalizing on these features, and because they're doing that, it provides a wonderful sort of laboratory in the wild, you might say, for identifying where people are making those inferences, what kinds of predictable sorts of projections they make to fill in those gaps because the stories are exposing them.
如果一个惊人的结局是通过利用我们的偏见和心理捷径来起作用的，那么观察一个好故事的机制是否能揭示出关于思维轮廓的重要信息？在我们探索世界时，我们的大脑正在将非常碎片化、参差不齐的信息组合成一个连贯的故事，而故事、电影、小说等所做的事情，正是利用了这些特征。正因为它们在这样做，这就提供了一个极好的“野外实验室”，你可以这么说，用来识别人们在何处做出这些推论，他们为了填补这些空白会做出什么样的可预测的投射，因为故事把它们暴露出来了。
If the idea of using movies as a brain scan seems far-fetched, think about what scientists have learned in recent years by studying magic tricks. So, you're going to be holding the coin like this, boom. This is a popular YouTube magician known as the Russian Genius. For this I will be showing you a coin, Venice, which looks something like this. In this clip, which we've altered a bit for clarity, he puts a coin in his left hand, gives it a dramatic squeeze, boom, and opens his hand.
如果把电影比作大脑扫描仪的想法显得有些遥不可及，想想科学家近年来通过研究魔术所学到的东西。所以，你会像这样拿着硬币，砰。这是YouTube上的一位知名魔术师，被称为“俄罗斯天才”。接下来我将向大家展示一枚硬币，威尼斯，它看起来大致是这样的。在这个片段中，为了清晰起见，我们做了一些修改，他把一枚硬币放在左手里，用力戏剧性地一捏，砰，然后张开手。
And then it just disappears just like that. In fact, the coin is whisked away by the magician's other hand when we're not looking. But at this point, our minds have already filled in the gaps about cause and effect. That little squeeze of the hand, boom, it seems like it made the coin actually disappear. In this way a good magician exploits gaps in our attention and our tendency to draw rapid but flawed inferences.
然后它就那样消失了。事实上，当我们不注意的时候，这枚硬币已经被魔术师的另一只手拿走了。但在此时，我们的大脑已经自动脑补了因果关系的空白。手轻轻一捏，砰，看起来就像是让硬币真的消失了。通过这种方式，一个优秀的魔术师利用了我们注意力中的空白，以及我们做出快速但有缺陷的推论的倾向。
In fact there's a whole thriving sub-area of cognitive science that has realized that magic tricks are this really fertile ground for discovering things about limitations in our visual perception and aspects of our attention that magicians have capitalized on for decades and centuries even. And the kinds of tricks that brilliant filmmakers and novelists, and short story writers, and playwrights use are themselves also magic tricks that also take advantage of these features in the way that people work. So when we dissect them, we can discover very, very reliable aspects of those tricks turn out to be very important clues about the way that people think. Now, there are many kinds of surprises in narratives, and at the most basic level, you can have someone jump out from behind a wall and scream at you, and that's one kind of surprise, and it's scary. But in some ways, you are focused on a different kind of surprise, a more sophisticated
事实上，认知科学中有一个蓬勃发展的子领域，他们意识到魔术是发现视觉感知局限性和注意力方面问题的一片极其肥沃的土地，魔术师几十甚至几百年来一直在利用这些局限性。杰出的电影制作人、小说家、短篇小说家和剧作家所使用的各种戏法，本身也是魔术，它们同样利用了人类运作方式中的这些特征。因此，当我们剖析它们时，我们可以发现，这些戏法中非常非常可靠的方面，原来是关于人类思考方式的重要线索。现在，叙事中有许多种惊喜，在最基础的层面，你可以让人从墙后跳出来对你尖叫，这是一种惊喜，而且很吓人。但在某些方面，你关注的是另一种不同的惊喜，一种更复杂的
kind of surprise. What kind of surprise is that? Yes, so I'm especially looking in this study at surprises where what you thought was happening, what you thought was going on, what you thought the circumstances were in a story turn out to be something different and that you're convinced by the story that it was something different all along. So that it's this retrospective surprise where the rug is pulled out from under you, the tables are turned, you, instead of thinking that the story has told you one thing and now it's telling you something different, what is going on here. You believe that you were mistaken and that now you have a new understanding of what was going on
惊喜。那是什么样的惊喜呢？是的，所以我在这项研究中特别关注这样的惊喜：在故事中，你以为正在发生的事情、你以为正在进行的事情、你以为的情况，结果却变成了完全不同的东西，而且故事让你确信它自始至终就是那种不同的东西。所以这是一种回溯式的惊喜，地毯被从你脚下抽走，形势逆转，你不再认为故事之前告诉了你一件事，现在又告诉你一件事——这到底是怎么回事。你会相信自己之前弄错了，现在你对以前发生的事情有了新的理解。
before. So we're going to take a look at two movies both of which in some ways are these finely executed plots with these as you call it these finely oiled traps that are embedded inside them. And the first one is M. Knight-Charmelon's The Sixth Sense. A dedicated psychologist, Malcolm Crowe, is working with a troubled child named Cole. And after much effort, the psychologist finally gets Cole to open up about what's bothering him. Let's listen to a clip.
所以我们要看两部电影，这两部电影在某些方面都是精心编排的情节，里面嵌入了你所谓的“精心设计的陷阱”。第一部是M·奈特·沙马兰的《第六感》。一位敬业的心理学家马尔科姆·克劳正在和一个名叫科尔的问题儿童合作。经过一番努力，心理学家终于让科尔敞开心扉，说出了困扰他的事情。让我们听一段音频。
I want to tell you my secret now. OK. I see dead people. I'm gonna tell you my secret now. I see dead people. In your dreams? While you're awake? Dead people like engraves and coffins. Walking around like regular people. They don't see each other. They only see what they want to see.
我现在想告诉你我的秘密。好吧。我看到了死人。我要把我的秘密告诉你了。我看到了死人。在你的梦里？在你醒着的时候？像坟墓和棺材里的死人。像正常人一样走来走去。他们看不见彼此。他们只看到他们想看的东西。
They don't know they're dead. Vera, tell us about the surprise that follows. Yes, well, so as I expect most people at this point, no. What happens is that the psychologist who's helping this boy who can see dead people come to grips with his gift and so on is himself one of these dead people who can't see the other dead people who doesn't know he's dead that's his reality. And of course this movie has long been held up as a power gone of the surprise ending for
他们不知道自己已经死了。维拉，给我们讲讲随后的惊喜吧。好的，所以正如我所料，此时大多数人都知道了。发生的事情是，这位正在帮助一个能看到死人的男孩正视他的天赋等等的心理学家，他自己就是这些死人之一，他看不到其他死人，他不知道自己已经死了，这就是他的现实。当然，这部电影长期以来一直被奉为惊悚结局的典范，原因正是
precisely the reasons you just laid out which which is as you watch the movie, you are taken in and at the point at which the surprises reveal to you, you look back and you see the numerous clues that was scattered throughout the movie, including in this last clip by the way, where a cold the child says, you know, they're everywhere I see them all the time. And of course, Cole is actually talking and seeing someone who actually is dead. That's exactly right. And part of what happens is, you know, in all kinds of stories, having characters with different kinds of information about what's going on gives the story a justification for leading the viewer to pay attention to certain things and not pay attention to other things.
你刚才列举的，也就是说，当你观看这部电影时，你被吸引进去了，而当惊喜向你揭晓的那一刻，你回过头去，看到了散落在整部电影中的无数线索，顺便说一句，包括在这个最后的片段中，科尔这个孩子说，你知道的，他们无处不在，我随时都能看到他们。当然，科尔实际上是在跟一个已经死去的人说话并看着他。完全正确。部分原因在于，你知道，在各种各样的故事中，让拥有关于正在发生的事情的不同信息的角色，为故事引导观众关注某些事情而不关注其他事情提供了理由。
And we're inclined to forget or lose track of possible discrepancies between characters' perspectives. So in the sixth sense, we lose track of the fact that Cole knows things that other characters may not know and he sees things that other characters may not see and that we're seeing what he sees. I wanna spend some time exploring different elements
而我们倾向于忘记或忽略角色视角之间可能存在的差异。所以在《第六感》中，我们忽略了这样一个事实：科尔知道一些其他角色可能不知道的事情，他看到了其他角色可能看不到的东西，而我们正在看他看到的东西。我想花一些时间探讨不同的元素
of this plot and how they might reveal things about our minds. We actually had Danny Coniman on Hidden Brain recently and he talked to me about the availability bias, things that spring more readily to mind are seen as more plausible than things that spring less readily to mind. Now most of us find it easier to bring to mind a psychologist who's dealing with a patient
这个情节以及它们如何揭示关于我们思维的事情。我们最近请到了丹尼·卡尼曼做客《隐藏的大脑》，他跟我谈到了可得性偏差，即更容易浮现在脑海的事情，比那些不那么容易浮现在脑海的事情，被认为更具合理性。现在，我们大多数人都觉得，更容易联想到的是一个正在处理饱受幻觉折磨的病人的心理学家，
who's suffering from hallucinations rather than a scenario where a kid can talk to dead people. So one scenario seems more likely, the availability bias fools us into ignoring the less likely scenario. That's right. And of course also the fact that these scenarios that are more available to us are also made more available to us by also made more available to us by the film itself because we have a character there, the psychologist who is
而不是一个小孩能和死人说话的场景。因此，其中一个场景似乎更有可能发生，可得性偏差欺骗了我们，让我们忽略了那个可能性较小的场景。没错。当然，这些对我们来说更容易获得的场景，也正是由电影本身通过安插一个角色——也就是心理学家——让我们更容易获得的，
absolutely operating on the assumption that he's not a dead person, he is a living psychologist, he's helping this child with things. As pathologies more severe than initially assessed, suffering from visual hallucinations, paranoia, school AIDS, schizophrenia. And this hypothesis about what's going on is very available to us because it's presented to us directly on screen as well. There's another moment in the movie that takes advantage of a powerful limitation in our thinking. Malcolm Crow, the dead psychologist played by Bruce Willis, is sitting across the room
他绝对是在“自己不是死人，而是一个活着的心理学家，正在帮助这个孩子解决问题”的假设下运作的。这比最初评估的病理更严重，患有视觉幻觉、偏执狂、学校恐惧症、精神分裂症。关于正在发生的事情的这个假设对我们来说非常容易理解，因为它也直接呈现在银幕上。电影中还有另一个时刻，利用了我们思维中的一个强大局限性。由布鲁斯·威利斯扮演的已故心理学家马尔科姆·克劳，正坐在房间的另一头，
from the troubled child's mother. They're in the living room and we assume they've just had a difficult, private conversation. The mother is looking down, she never looks at the psychologist. She doesn't even acknowledge he's there, which turns out to be a very significant detail, but we don't know that just yet. Then, her son enters the room. She gets up to see him. Hey, baby. How was he today? Now all that went by really fast, but let's return to this detail that the mother never
面对着问题儿童的母亲。他们坐在起居室里，我们以为他们刚刚进行了一场艰难的私人谈话。母亲一直低着头，她从不看心理学家一眼。她甚至没有承认他在场，事实证明这是一个非常重要的细节，但我们当时并不知道。然后，她的儿子走进了房间。她起身去看他。嘿，宝贝。他今天表现怎么样？刚才这一切发生得太快了，但让我们回到这个细节：母亲从没
looked at Malcolm Crow. We think she didn't look at him because she was distraught about a conversation they'd had, but really, the mother can't see him because he's a ghost. As a dead guy, the psychologist doesn't notice anything strange either. According to the internal logic of his character, he just sits there, seeing whatever he wants to see. They only see what they want to see. They don't know they're dead. Here's the thing, we don't notice anything strange ourselves.
看一眼马尔科姆·克劳。我们以为她不看他是因为她对他们刚刚进行的那场对话感到心烦意乱，但实际上，母亲看不见他，因为他是个幽灵。作为一个死人，心理学家也没有注意到任何异常。根据他角色的内在逻辑，他只是坐在那里，看着他想看的一切。他们只看到他们想看的东西。他们不知道自己已经死了。关键是，我们自己也没有注意到任何异常。
Relief to a conclusion about what's going on, and we assume that the characters in the movie are seeing and hearing and thinking what we see and hear and think. As far as Vera is concerned, this blind spot, imagining that other people think like we think, this is the mother of all blind spots. Cognitive scientists call it the curse of knowledge. So the things that we know, we find it very difficult, you know, essentially impossible to fully suppress that knowledge when we're thinking about what other people might know.
我们对正在发生的事情得出结论，并假设电影中的角色所看到、听到和想到的，就是我们所看到、听到和想到的。在维拉看来，这种盲点——想象别人和我们的想法一样——是所有盲点之母。认知科学家称之为“知识的诅咒”。所以我们所知道的事情，当我们思考别人可能知道什么时，我们会发现很难，可以说是完全不可能完全压制这种知识。
It seeps in and colors and influences our speculation about the perspective of other people. So when we first encounter this scene, we have an understanding of what it probably means and we readily project that understanding onto our speculation about what both of the characters in this scene think and know and understand and this affects how we interpret their actions. You know, one of the other things I found really lovely about the movie in the context of reading your book is that it plays on how we draw implicit conclusions about the world. So in the opening scenes of the movie, don't you remember your own patients?
它会渗透进来，并给和影响我们对他人视角的推测。因此，当我们第一次遇到这个场景时，我们对它可能意味着什么有了一种理解，并且我们很容易将这种理解投射到我们对这个场景中两个角色的想法、知识和理解的推测上，这反过来影响了我们对他们行为的解释。你知道，在阅读你的书的背景下，我觉得这部电影真正迷人的地方之一，在于它利用了我们如何对世界得出内隐结论。所以在电影的开场场景中，难道你不记得你自己的病人了吗？
We see the psychologist get shot by a former patient. You found me! You just give be a chance. Ah! Ah! When we see him walking around sometime later, my name is Dr. Malcolm Crowe. We're supposed to meet today, but I missed our appointment.
我们看到心理学家被一个前病人开枪击中。你找到我了！你只是给我一个机会。啊！啊！当我们看到他在一段时间后走来走去时，我的名字叫马尔科姆·克劳医生。我们本该今天见面，但我错过了我们的预约。
We assume he's recovered when in fact he's a ghost. Now, no one tells us he survived. We don't even think about it consciously. The information is powerful because it's actually implicit. We simply don't notice how our minds are constantly and consistently leaping to conclusions outside of our conscious awareness. That's right, and that's, of course, how we navigate the world all the time. It's how we make sense of stories that we tell one another.
我们以为他康复了，而实际上他是一个幽灵。现在，没有人告诉我们他生还了。我们甚至没有有意识地去想它。这条信息之所以强大，是因为它是内隐的。我们只是没有注意到我们的大脑是如何在没有我们有意识感知的情况下，不断且一贯地跃向结论的。没错，当然，这就是我们一直在世界上穿梭的方式。这也是我们理解彼此讲述的故事的方式。
We leave lots of material implicit for other people to fill in. We don't feel like we have to be labor over every point of connection and make these things abundantly clear, but it's also true as we make our way through the world all the time we have only partial information about what we're encountering, what kind of situation we're in, what other people think or know or intend, and part of the essence of being a person and moving fluently through the world is conjuring up all of these inferences to bridge the gaps between what we know for certain. There's one final idea I want to explore in connection with the sixth sense. You know we all think that we understand
我们留下了很多内隐的材料供其他人去填补。我们并不觉得自己必须煞费苦心地去纠缠每一个连接点，并把这些事情交代得极其清楚，但同样真实的是，在我们在这个世界上前行的过程中，我们对所遭遇的事情、我们处于什么样的情况、其他人怎么想或知道什么或打算做什么，只有部分的信息，而作为一个在世界上流利行走的人的本质的一部分，就是召唤所有这些推论，来弥合我们确切知道的事情之间的鸿沟。我还想探讨与《第六感》相关的最后一个想法。你知道，我们都认为我们理解
information or we understand the world by carefully amassing and processing all the evidence. But in reality, we start with some piece of information, and then we build on it. But this initial information acts in some ways like an anchor. It influences everything else we learn afterwards. Tell me about the anchoring effect and the role it plays in the sixth sense. Well, yes. So actually, you refer to this initial scene, right, where he shot,
信息，或者我们通过仔细收集和处理所有证据来理解世界。但实际上，我们是从某条信息开始的，然后在此基础上进行构建。但这个初始信息在某种程度上就像一个锚。它会影响我们以后学到的所有其他信息。跟我讲讲锚定效应及其在《第六感》中所起的作用。好的，是的。实际上，你提到了最初的场景，也就是他被枪击的那一幕，
but it immediately followed by a cut to him walking around afterwards. So you have this moment of inference that you make indeed, as you say, without probably even noticing that it was an inference at all. It seems as if the film has showed you something. And it does this initially, and then it does it repeatedly over the course of the early scenes of the film, where you're given the psychologists understanding of what's going on over and over again. And with anchoring, even if you're skeptical about this framing, the fact that you got it right away will tend to constrain the directions in which your imagination goes. But your inclination is to have that initial framing of the circumstances that he sets forth as your anchor and then to adjust away from it and try to say, well, maybe it's not quite like that,
但这紧接着是一个切换到他在事后走来走去的镜头。所以你进行了这样一个推论的时刻，正如你所说，可能你根本没有注意到这压根就是一个推论。电影好像向你展示了某些东西。它一开始就这样做，然后在电影的前期场景中重复这样做，让你一遍又一遍地接受心理学家对所发生事情的理解。有了锚定效应，即使你对这种框架持怀疑态度，你立刻接受它的事实也会倾向于限制你的想象力发展的方向。但你的倾向是将他阐述的对环境的最初框架作为你的锚，然后在此基础上进行调整，试图去说，好吧，也许情况不完全是那样，
but not to throw it away altogether. And so that's what makes the anchor so powerful, which is we think that we are open to re-evaluating it, to throwing it aside, tossing it aside. But in fact, even when we're willing to do that, the anchor still exerts some kind of influence over us and prevents us from drifting too far away. That's right. And this is, of course, the essence of red herrings in general. It's even if a red herring, even if you see that it's a red herring, even if you are completely not taken
但而不是把它完全抛弃。这就是使锚如此强大的原因，也就是说，我们认为自己愿意重新评估它，把它抛在一边，扔掉它。但事实上，即使在我们愿意这样做的时候，锚仍然对我们施加某种影响，并阻止我们漂得太远。没错。当然，这也就是一般意义上的“红鲱鱼”（干扰项）的本质。也就是说，即使是一条红鲱鱼，即使你看出它是一条红鲱鱼，即使你完全没有被那条红鲱鱼所暗示的推测路线所吸引，它仍然会对那些容易浮现在脑海中、对你可用的推测产生一种引力。当我们回来时，我们将看看另一部90年代的电影，它也以令人惊掉下巴的情节反转而闻名。《非常嫌疑犯》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维达纳姆。今天我正在采访维拉·托宾，她是世界上最早研究情节反转如何为人类思维运作提供一扇窗户的认知科学家之一。作为她研究的一部分，她花了很多时间看电影，寻找一种特定类型的惊喜。
in by the line of speculation that that red herring suggests, it still will exert a sort of gravitational pull on the kinds of speculation that will come readily to mind that will be available to you. When we come back, we look at another movie from the 1990s that's also famous for its jaw-dropping plot twist. The usual suspects. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Today I'm talking to Vera Tobin, one of the world's first cognitive scientists, to study how plot twists can offer a window into the workings of the human mind. As part of her research, she spent a lot of time watching movies, looking for a particular kind of surprise.
这种惊喜通常出现在电影的高潮部分，并颠覆之前发生的一切，所以你知道的，这是巨大的情节反转。她把这类反转称为“地毯抽离者”。在本节中，我们将审视现代电影中最伟大的“地毯抽离者”之一——1995年的《非常嫌疑犯》。告诉我你把那个纽约来的瘸子抓进去了。他提到了凯瑟·索泽吗？谁？
Surprises where they come climatically at the end of a film and they overturn everything that went before, so you know big plot twists. She calls these kinds of twists, rug pullers. In this segment, we're going to examine one of the greatest rug pullers in modern cinema. The usual suspects from 1995. Tell me you got the cripple in there from New York. Did he mention Kaiser Soze? Who?
在电影中，警方正在寻找一个名叫凯瑟·索泽的神秘罪犯。我们对索泽的几乎所有了解，都是通过电影的叙述者——一个一瘸一拐的混混维巴尔过滤后得知的。他由凯文·史派西饰演。在这一幕中，维巴尔向调查人员讲述了凯瑟·索泽的传说。据说他是土耳其人。有人说他父亲是德国人。从来没有人相信他是真的。从来没有人认识他，也没有人见过任何直接为他工作的人。
In the movie, the police are looking for a mysterious criminal named Kaiser Soze. Nearly everything we know about Soze is filtered through the movie's narrator, a limping small-time crook named Verbal. He's played by Kevin Spacey. In the scene, Verbal tells an investigator about the legend of Kaiser Soze. He's supposed to be Turkish. Some say his father was German. Nobody ever believed he was real. Nobody ever knew him or so anybody that ever worked directly for him.
但听小林的话，任何人都可以为索泽工作。你永远不知道。这就是他的力量。所以情节反转是，维巴尔就是凯瑟·索泽。情节反转的另一部分是，我们所看到的整个展开的故事，也就是维巴尔讲述他所经历的事情时，看起来像是对过去神秘事件的某种直接闪回——
But to hear Kobayashi tell it anybody could have worked for Susie. You never knew. That was his power. So the plot twist is verbal is Kairzor Sosa. And the other part of the plot twist is that the whole unfolding story that we've seen as Verbal tells his account of what happened that appeared to be a sort of straightforward flashback to the mysterious events of the past. McManus came to us with the job. Fenster got the vans.
麦克马纳斯带给我们这笔生意。芬斯特弄到了货车。波克尼提供了武器。我拿出了如何去做的方案，所以没有人被杀。但基顿……结果这一切都只是他为了给自己争取时间逃跑而编造的一个故事。我们都知道这是可以做到的。我琢磨着要错做就得杀人，要做对得要五个人，五个人的意思就是基顿。
Pockney supplied the hardware. I came through with how to do it, so no one got killed. But Keaton. Turns out to all have been just a story that he was spinning in order to buy himself time in order to escape. We all knew it could be done. The way I figured to do it wrong meant killing, to do it right took five men, five men meant Keaton.
我想，我们在这里被误导了，部分原因是我们接受了向我们讲述故事的人的信仰和世界观，而讲故事的人塑造了我们看待故事的方式。完全正确。所以发生的情况是，叙事越具沉浸感，我们就越倾向于采取
I wonder who are misdirected here partly because we adopt the beliefs and worldview of the people who narrate the stories to us, and the person who tells the story shapes the way we see the story. That's exactly right. So what happens is the more immersive a narrative is, the more and more we tend to take
某些人所说的“涉入式视角”，也就是说我们有这种沉浸式体验，我们的视角开始越来越与叙事所描绘和呈现给我们的视角保持一致。当然，你可以在各种电影中看到这一点，你知道的，你从受害者的角度讲述一个故事，它就变成了一个悲剧。你从劫匪的角度讲述关于银行抢劫的同一个故事，它就会变成一个潜在的有趣故事，甚至是一个成功完成抢劫的胜利故事。
what some people have called an inactive viewpoint, which is to say that we sort of have this immersive experience and our viewpoint begins to align more and more with the viewpoint that's being depicted to us and presented to us by the narrative. And of course you can see there's in all kinds of movies which is you know you tell the movie from the point of view of the victim, and it becomes a tragedy. You tell the same story about a bank heist from the point of view of the robbers, and it becomes, you know, potentially a funny story, or even a Victoria story about a heist pulled off successfully.
故事的视角，故事的叙述者，在塑造我们对什么是真实的、什么是虚假的看法方面起着核心作用。那一刻，我并不害怕。我知道我没有做任何他们能把我怎么样的事。况且，这很有趣。我得装得好像我很出名似的。对事件及其意义的 framing（建构）、哪些部分值得关注以及它们的含义，所有这些都是故事向我们讲述的方式以及讲故事的人的视角的一部分。而再次强调，这一切大多是无意识的。
The point of view of the story, the narrator of the story, plays really a central role in shaping how we think about what's real and what's not real. At that point, I wasn't scared. I knew I hadn't done anything they could do me for. Besides, it was fun. I got to make like I was notorious. The framing of events and their significance and what parts are worth paying attention to and what they mean, all of these things are part of the way that the story is being told to us and the viewpoint of the person telling the story. And again, this is all mostly unconscious.
我们其实并没有在想，这就是视角，这就是我正在采用的框架。正如你所说，当一个好故事开始展开时，我们只是被卷了进去，然后在某种程度上，我们的批判能力被搁置了。没错。所以，情绪参与度越高，故事越引人入胜、越生动，我们就越少去关注故事的运作机制，去质疑、怀疑、保持警惕并监督诸如“我应该信任这个来源吗？”之类的问题。
We're not actually thinking, this is the point of view, this is the frame I'm adopting. As you say, when a good story starts to unfold, we just get swept along and then, in some ways, our critical faculties are put on hold. That's right. So the more emotionally engaged, the more gripping and vivid the story is, the less attention we're paying to sort of the apparatus of the story and questioning and wondering and being on guard and monitoring these questions about, should I trust this source?
这里的差异在哪里，等等。你只是沉浸在那个视角中。当然，这意味着如果你是一个艺术家，在创作电影或写书时，你想做的是利用这样一种事实：在高度情绪化的环境中，人们比在其他情况下更容易轻信。没错。
What are the discrepancies here and so on? You're just immersed in that perspective. And of course, then that means that if you're an artist, creating a movie or writing a book, what you want to do is take advantage of the fact that in highly emotional settings, people are more likely to be gullible than in other situations. That's right.
所以我认为在很多情况下，人们倾向于认为情节反转在某种程度上是对立的，你知道的，它们是噱头，它们的运作水平与沉浸式叙事、生动的角色塑造、深度和复杂性等其他文学和电影价值观相悖，但实际上它们往往恰好利用了这些东西。你知道的，维拉，当我在读你的书时，我开始思考《非常嫌疑犯》是如何利用我们对维巴尔的同情这一事实的。因为他有残疾。在我们的脑海中，很难看到一个要求我们同情的人也可能是一个精神病患者，在某种程度上，这需要一种能够同时容纳这两个对立观点的复杂性，这太难做到了，以至于我们索性抛弃了其中一个。
And so I think in a lot of circumstances, people tend to think of plot twists as being in some way opposed to, you know, their gimmicky, their operating on a level that is counter to these other sort of literary and filmic values of immersive storytelling, vivid characterization, depth and complexity and so on, but actually often they capitalize on exactly those things. You know, as I was reading your book, Vera, I got to thinking about how the usual suspects also takes advantage of the fact that we have sympathy for verbal because he has a disability. And it's difficult in our minds to see that someone who demands our sympathy might also be a psychopath that in some ways it requires a certain complexity of sort of holding these two opposing ideas simultaneously that is so hard to do that we just sort of jettison one of them.
嗯，是的，刻板印象可以以这种方式被利用，事实上这也是故事内部建构的一部分，对吧？所以，你知道，维巴尔患有脑瘫，或者他看起来是这样的，对吧？但当他走到城市中，他的跛态逐渐消失等等，这是最终场景的一部分。所以这个想法是，这个角色正在利用这样一种事实：人们通常倾向于认为身体残疾或其他刻板印象漏洞的人不知为何不适合担任其他类型的角色，他也在利用这一点。魔鬼曾经把戏演得最绝的一次，就是让全世界相信他根本不存在。就这样，他消失了。
Well, yeah, so stereotypes can be taken advantage of in these ways, and in fact that's part of the framing within the story, right? So, you know, verbal has cerebral pals palsy and or he seems to, right? But part of the final scene as he walks out into the city and his limp melts away and so on. So the idea is that the character was taking advantage of the fact that people often tend to see people with physical disabilities or other kinds of stereotyped vulnerabilities as somehow not eligible for other kinds of roles and that he's capitalizing on that as well. The greatest trick the devil ever pulled was convincing the world he didn't exist. And like that, he's gone.
你知道，心理学家有时会谈到“后见之明偏误”，也就是一旦事件展开，你就会觉得自己从一开始就知道它会发生。在某种程度上，一旦你看到了《第六感》或《非常嫌疑犯》中的揭秘，你回过头来，内心深处会有一部分为自己没有看出来而懊恼，但也会有一部分在说：“是的，当然，我其实真的看到了所有这些东西。我其实，这对我来说确实说得通。”是的，你可以说服自己进入这样一种状态，在那里你说：“哦，是的，你知道，我，我，这是，我有一半相信，你知道，我，我是在轨道上的，比你实际可能感受到的要多，对吧？”所以这一切
You know, psychologists sometimes talk about the hindsight bias, which is once an event has unfolded, you feel like you knew all along that it was going to happen. At some point, once you see the reveal in the sixth sense or the usual suspects, you go back and there's a part of you that kicks yourself or not seeing it, but there's a part of you that also says, yes, of course, I actually did see all those things. I actually, this actually makes sense to me. Yes, you can talk yourself into this position where you say, oh, yes, you know, I, I, it was, I halfway oh yes, you know, I, it was, I have way believed that, you know, I was, I was on the track, more than you really were potentially, right? So all of this
都有助于向你推销这样一个观点，即这个故事对你真的很公平，线索就在那里，事后看来是可以猜到的。YouTube上有一个视频，记录了一个十几岁的男孩坐在沙发上第一次观看《第六感》结局的情景。拍他的人简直无法抑制内心的兴奋。别看手机了。只管看那他妈的……当沙发上的小孩得知电影的巨大秘密时，他经历了几个阶段。困惑……
helps to, to sell you on this idea that the story really played fair with you, that the clues were there, that it was guessable after the fact. There's a clip on YouTube of a teenage boy on the couch watching the end of the sixth sense for the first time. The person filming him cannot contain his excitement. Don't check your phone. Just watch the fucking... As the kid on the couch learns the movie's big secret, he goes through a few stages. Confusion...
等一下。理解？我的天哪！然后他转向镜头，露出一副欣喜若狂的表情。而拿摄像机的那个家伙，他欣喜若狂。呵呵呵呵。就好像他是第一次看到这个惊喜一样。呵呵呵呵。那这里到底发生了什么？
Wait a second. Understanding? Oh my God! Then he turns to the camera with a look of total glee. And the guy with the camera, he's euphoric. Hehehehe. It's as if he is seeing the surprise for the first time. Hehehe. So what's going on here?
为什么故事中的惊喜让我们如此高兴？维拉说有几个原因。首先，毕竟这只是一个故事，而不是现实生活。所以这是一种对惊险刺激的安全探索，而没有那些在现实生活中可能会让惊喜变得非常令人不快的结果。所以，你知道，这也是为什么坐过山车真的很有趣，而从悬崖上掉下来却没那么有趣的原因。对吧？另一个原因是，当它们构建得好时，在现实生活中，你并不一定能拥有
Why do the surprises and stories leave us so delighted? Vera says there are a few reasons. One is, after all, it really is a story, not real life. So this kind of safe exploration of the thrill of surprise without the possible outcomes that would make surprises so unpleasant potentially in real life. So, you know, it's part of why it's really fun to go on a roller coaster and it's not so much fun to fall off a cliff. Right? And the other reason is that when they're constructed well, in real life, you don't have necessarily
通往这些突如其来的惊喜的前期铺垫，在那个铺垫中你可以反思之前发生的事情，并发现惊喜具有启发性，对吧？它为之前发生的事件增添了新的、有趣的意义，但对于一个精心制作的惊喜来说，这一切都为你铺垫好了。这有点像我们从解开填字游戏或难题中获得的快乐。在某个时刻，那些看起来令人困惑的事情各就各位，看到所有部分如何完美地结合在一起，会产生一种强烈的快乐。完全正确。所以故事能为你做的是构建这种顿悟
a lead up to these sudden surprises where you can reflect back on what happened before and discover that the surprise is enlightening, right? That it lends new, interesting significance to the events that happened before, but with a well-made surprise, this has been set up for you. It's a little bit like the pleasure we get from solving a crossword puzzle or a difficult problem. It's at some point things that seem confusing all fall into place and there's an intense pleasure at seeing how all the parts come together beautifully. Exactly. So what a story can do for you is construct this insight
体验，让你感觉不是有什么东西蒙蔽了你的双眼，也不是你只是大吃一惊，而是有这样一种体验：仿佛你对事情是如何组合在一起的有了真正的“啊哈”时刻。这是人类非常喜欢的东西。维拉·托宾是凯斯西储大学的认知科学家。她是《惊喜的要素：我们的心理极限与情节的满足感》一书的作者。维拉，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。
experience where you feel not that something has blindsided you or that you were just taken by surprise, but this experience that feels as if you have a real aha moment about how things fit together. And that is something that humans like a lot. Vera Tobin is a cognitive scientist at Case Western Reserve University. She's the author of the book, Elements of Surprise, our mental limits and the satisfaction of plot. Vera, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
本周的节目由劳拉·夸雷尔制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕尔特·沙阿和托马斯·刘。我们今天的话题引起了我的强烈共鸣，因为故事是我们《隐藏的大脑》经常思考的事情。我们努力寻找能够将研究和想法带入现实的故事，我们经常花几个月的时间来打磨这些故事，以确保我们为您提供最实用的要点。如果您曾受益于从我们的节目中学到的想法，请考虑在 donate.npr.org slash hidden brain 上进行捐赠。网址再重复一遍，是 donate.npr.org slash hidden brain。您的捐赠将支持您的当地公共广播电台和
This week's show was produced by Laura Quarell and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Parth Shah and Thomas Liu. Our topic today resonated deeply with me because stories are something we think about a lot at Hidden Brain. We work hard to find stories that bring research and ideas to life, and we often spend months working on those stories to ensure that we are providing you with the most useful takeaways. If you have ever benefited from the ideas you've learned from our show, please consider making a gift at donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. That address again is donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. Your donation will support your local public radio station and
我们的工作。谢谢你们，我们真的非常感激。我们本周的无名英雄是阿尔伯特·李。阿尔伯特协助管理《隐藏的大脑》的预算，他对细节的关注符合你对这个角色所期望的一切。据说每个优秀企业的背后都有一个伟大的会计师。在我们的例子中，这绝对是真的。谢谢你，阿尔伯特。那么你怎么看？你喜欢达斯·维达实际上是个卢姆斯塔德这个事实吗？太棒了！不！我是香卡·维达纳姆，这里是NPR。
our work. And thanks, we're truly grateful. Our unsung hero this week is Albert Lee. Albert helps to manage the budget for hidden brain and his attention to detail is everything you would want from someone in his role. It's said that behind every good business is a great accountant. And in our case, that's certainly true. Thank you, Albert. So what did you think? Did you like the fact that Darth Vader was actually a loomstad? Yeah! No! I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR.
这里是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。